your iconic hat the top hat it instantly
made you special am i correct
i don't know i mean it it definitely
became like a
a thing that got recognized it wasn't
intentional
you know so i didn't sort of see it
coming but then eventually it did it
became like
a signature kind of a thing do you still
wear it on stage yeah i wear it on stage
and you know for photos and stuff but
you don't wear it on the street anymore
because it's just
it's ridiculous
i couldn't think of a better word when
you were first starting out did you wear
it in the street the hat uh-huh
you did and would it blow off in the
wind because it was it's a stove pipe
kind of hat
you know what it's like it's it's just
tall enough to be tall but she's just
short enough not to get knocked out by a
gust of wind
but doesn't it take balls to wear a hat
like that seriously i mean people notice
you when you wear a hat like that
i bet you caught a lot of [ __ ] for where
were you when you decided to wear that
hat
yeah that's a good question i i no one
ever gave me [ __ ] for it no
um well you're talking you know because
you just wear it and you're like in your
in everybody's face especially
you know that was sort of like the way
it was anyway it was sort of like
how old were you um 20. okay is it true
you stole that hat
uh-huh and you couldn't at the time you
had no money i mean it's pretty
legendary you guys were broke
i was i was walking around melrose we
had a show uh
that night at the uh at the whiskey and
uh
i guess i was just calm you know
cruising around looking for shits in
pilfer
and uh did you steal a lot of stuff at
that point in your life where you were
no i wasn't i sort of got past my klepto
phase but every so often i would lift
something that
wasn't going to turn anybody a huge
profit you know how do you lift a hat
that size though
just um just sort of walk out with it
casually and people just don't really
notice
in a way that became like your good luck
symbol and when you steal it doesn't
that [ __ ] up your karma maybe maybe
that's why
because not too long after that i got
drunk at the cat house and passed out
and someone stole it from me
oh is that true yeah and then you had to
go get another one yeah you paid for
that then i had to pay for the next one
how many of those hats do you own i only
have like four oh you do
yeah and one of them lemmy just gave me
let me from motorhead yeah no i
you know i'm not saying this
procedurally not that you had a
calculated move but it is a brilliant
move because it distinguished you right
away and if you remember the time
that guns and roses became huge there
were so many bands i mean
like like and maybe you resented like
did you resent motley crue
were you and guns and roses sort of the
anti well
molly crew i never resented molly crew
because they always
i first became aware of them um
actually nikki sixx back when he had a
band called london so he was like the
original sort of glam metal guy right
from
from the 70s from the late 70s so when
he started motley crew it was way ahead
of everybody else
so you didn't represent those people
there were a bunch of bands that kind of
but then after that then everybody was
you know i think from
from van halen on really it was when
that sort of whole spandex thing
yeah came in and we were definitely the
antithesis of that
you hated that but it was weird axel
then would sometimes go on stage
and almost you know where like the kilt
and the stockings and the you know like
he almost
went to that look but no it was still
different it was right
and it was it's just an attitude you
know i think the thing about
guns and roses in the club days i mean
in general
was was you know just a
a very much of [ __ ] you right this is
what we do which
was was a genuine attitude you know and
how
how how we went around whereas everybody
else was all trying to jump on the
bandwagon would guns and roses ever have
a meeting about clothing
no this i know this sounds weird no but
but think about it if one of the guys
showed up in spandex
or something that sort of was
reminiscent of of a spandex kind of band
or something
why didn't you sit those guys down and
say look we represent a certain thing in
rock and roll we're very pure about it
uh this looks ridiculous it wasn't his
image conscious
like we just sort of everybody had their
own sort of
thing thing what made it work to me is
that it was the songwriting process
didn't you write most of the music well
no no i mean i wrote i wrote a lot of uh
like i came in with a lot of really cool
sort of riff stuff that you'd be real
familiar with
but as a song as a songwriting team we
really did it together i mean the whole
band
yeah we'd sit in a room i mean those
songs really i mean uh
from a musical point of view i can't i
don't want to speak on a lyrical point
of view but
from a musical point of view they almost
wrote themselves like
a a song would take maybe you know some
hours to finish from top to bottom
amazing right you know so it was just
that kind of it was
but axel would come up with the lyric
mm-hmm unless
sometimes he came up with lyrics too the
way i heard it went in your band is that
you should be sitting there and go
no no no no no no no and then axel would
walk in and go hey man i could sing to
that well there's
there's no sort of set pattern i mean
songs really came out of um whatever was
going on at that time
so there's there's no rule as to how the
songs were written but
sometimes it'd be a riff and it would
inspire the other guy and and we'd start
jamming on it and then
axel would hear it and you know we're
talking about like the old stuff
and then uh you know as we got into like
the user illusions records
um then there was a whole you know then
it was a whole different dynamic
right you guys were famous by then and
well-paid
and so [ __ ] up that the whole process
changed it was just hard to get it
together to get in the studio to do that
but we finally did
it was actually a pretty amazing
accomplishment
you